Norm Peterson was one of the regular patrons
on Cheers, but where did George Wendt, the
actor who played him, go after the bar closed
up?
We've got the details right here.
While Cheers was still on the air, Wendt began
appearing in a series of sketches on Saturday
Night Live as Bob Swerski, a diehard Chicago
sports fan and host of the show "Bill Swerski's
Superfans."
"Da Bears!"
Wendt is a Chicago native himself, and as
a lifelong supporter of all Windy City sports
teams, he was instantly relatable to any other
local fans who were watching.
The sketches originally aired in the early
nineties, shortly before Cheers ended in 1993.
But that wasn't the end of Bob Swerski or
his passionate commentary on Chicago sports.
Wendt has returned to SNL to play Swerski
several times, with a total of nine appearances
between 1991 and 2003.
He's also shown up in character as Bob outside
of SNL.
In 2019, for example, he stopped by the ESPN+
series Peyton's Places, in which Peyton Manning
meets with a variety of interesting figures
to explore the history of football and the
cultural impact of the sport.
"Baby Peytonmy son, are you ready to be baptized
into the Bears superfandom?"
"Well, I'm not drunk, so no.”
A couple years after Cheers ended, Wendt got
his own starring sitcom gig.
Alas, The George Wendt Show reached nowhere
near the success of Cheers, airing for only
one season on CBS in 1995.
Perhaps a sitcom actually based around Norm
Peterson, whom the audience already knew and
loved, would've been a better move.
It took a few years after The George Wendt
Show wrapped for Wendt to nab another regular
TV gig.
In 1997, he appeared on the sitcom The Naked
Truth for three episodes.
Then in 2001, he appeared on another comedy
show, but this time, it was a series with
a different kind of audience than he was used
to, as he checked in for six episodes of Sabrina,
the Teenage Witch.
And in 2006, he was on the one-season WB sitcom
Modern Men as a guy who dished out dating
advice to confused, single men, even though
he'd been through a few divorces himself.
None of the shows that Wendt worked on after
leaving Boston really got the same reception
that Cheers did, but of course, that's the
type of iconic show that doesn't come around
very often.
And Wendt knows it.
While reflecting on the show's enduring popularity,
he told the Toronto Sun in 2017,
"It's such a pleasant surprise that something
you were a part of could make such an impact."
Besides Cheers, Wendt's longest-running TV
gig in terms of episode count was on the TBS
sitcom Clipped.
He played Buzzy, a guy who used to own a barbershop
named, naturally enough, Buzzy's.
In the show, he still works there, but now
the place is owned and managed by a fellow
named Ben.
Back in the day, Ben was an unpopular kid
in high school, but now that he's the boss
at Buzzy's, he's in charge of a few of his
old classmates.
Naturally, jealousy and petty antics ensue.
As for Buzzy, he might be beyond all that
high school drama, but he's got relationship
problems of his own, like figuring out how
to propose to the man of his dreams.
The show ran for ten episodes in the summer
of 2015 and was officially cancelled a few
months after the last episode aired.
On Cheers, George Wendt starred alongside
some pretty impressive names in the world
of comedy.
But recently, he's started working with someone
even more important to him: his wife, Bernadette
Birkett.
The couple starred together in a 2013 production
of the comedy play Never Too Late.
The original version of this show was popular
on Broadway in the 1960s, but it's not a very
well-known play today.
However, Wendt and Birkett's version was well-received
and positively reviewed.
In the play, Wendt played Harry Lambert, a
successful and traditionally-minded man who
owns a lumber company and thinks that his
wife, Edith, truly enjoys waiting on him hand
and foot.
But when Edith comes home with news that she's
pregnant, Harry is totally caught off guard.
Wendt and Birkett were praised for bringing
their real-life chemistry to the stage.
Robert Trussell of The Kansas City Star noted,
"The bombastic Harry is the showier role,
but Birkett goes for relatively subtle humor
in a precise, thoughtful performance.
For his part, Wendt delivers a master class
on comedic timing."
Although most of Wendt's acting work has been
on TV, he’s had plenty of film credits to
his name as well.
His career started with bit parts in movies,
and he appeared in a couple films that you
probably enjoyed as a kid.
In 1994, for example, he had a memorable supporting
role as a lumberyard clerk in The Little Rascals.
And of course we can't forget Spice World,
in which he played one of the guys pitching
film ideas for the girls to star in.
Wendt's more recent film credits include the
2017 Adam Sandler Netflix vehicle Sandy Wexler
and the comedy The Climb, which screened at
the 2019 Cannes Film Festival.
He's also got multiple projects in post-production.
And maybe one day we'll see the return of
Norm and the rest of the gang on the big screen.
When The Toronto Star asked him in 2017 about
the possibility of a Cheers reboot, he said,
"I think some sort of reboot is inevitable,
whether it's a movie or a show."
Alas, he also added,
"But I wouldn't hold my breath."
"Well, hear hear, huh?"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.